phoenix persönlich es ist so etwas wie
eine revolution im automobilbau die
umstellung auf alternative energie doch
die käufer die zögern und es gibt auch
bedenken wegen der arbeitsplätze bei mir
ist der vw chef herbert diess ist die
deutsche automobilindustrie nicht ein
bisschen langsam gewesen sie am so ein
bisschen den eindruck vermittelt als sei
das früher doch toll gewesen mit den
großen autos die kann man ganz toll für
tolle preise verkaufen
die ihre theater wie sie ist ist
überhaupt nicht langsam deutsche
automobilindustrie kommt zum richtigen
zeitpunkt sprechen es für volkswagen wir
haben im letzten jahr begonnen mit dem
audi e tron das erste premiumfahrzeug
vollständig zu elektrifizieren der
partei kann der erste sportwagen und
später in dem jahr kommt dann der e3 das
erste wirklich auch massen fähige
elektrofahrzeug
bis dahin hatten wir auch schon sehr
wettbewerbsfähige elektrofahrzeuge den
golf der jetzt fast 300 kilometer fährt
auch sehr gut nachgefragt ist wir haben
den elektrischen up als einstiegs
fahrzeug die deutsche automobil ist
kommt zum richtigen zeitpunkt
die muss aber ziemlich aufholen wir sind
in den usa
auch wenn sie das möglicherweise jetzt
erst einmal nicht so akzeptieren
wir sind hier auf einem forum in davos
wo der klimaschutz ganz weit oben steht
da wird auch viel geschäft gemacht kann
frage aber der klimaschutz ist das
beherrschende thema und da muss sehr
schnell etwas passieren aber das was als
an verkäufen gibt zum beispiel von
e-autos da zeigt ja nicht unbedingt dass
der autokäufer schon so weit ist doch
absolut wir haben deutliche zuwächse
airline 2009 10 ist der absatz von plug
in hybriden und elektrofahrzeuge über 60
prozent gestiegen in dem stagnierenden
markt nicht nur in deutschland sondern
praktisch europaweit wir haben deutlich
zuwächse in china also das
elektrofahrzeug schafft den durchbruch
wir haben einige märkte jetzt in denen
elektrofahrzeuge schon die am meisten
abgesetzten fahrzeuge sind holland zum
beispiel war tesla model 3 oder auch in
norwegen
es sind die meisten fahrzeuge legten das
geht schnell ist abhängig von
volkswirtschaft zur volkswirtschaft bei
uns wird das jahr 2020 ein sehr
wichtiges jahr mit eben den den neuen
fahrzeugen dann auch mit den
rahmenbedingungen die die regierung
setzt die natürlich auch sehr starke
kaufanreize setzen
elektrofahrzeuge sind heute schon im
unterhalt deutlich günstiger als
benziner oder diesel und damit rechnen
wir 20 20 21 wirklich mit ihm durch aber
warum ist dieses jahr jetzt so wichtig
2020 ist das ein entscheidendes jahr
auch für die frage wie man mit den
arbeitsplätzen hin kommt wir haben eine
beschäftigungs industrie im automobilbau
die ja fast bis zu einer millionen
beschäftigte geht da sind jetzt zahlen
publiziert worden die macht einem angst
und bange was da an arbeitsplätzen
verloren geht
ja das glaube ich kann man kann man
schon stark relativieren da es ist
wenigstens natürlich verursacht durch
elektrofahrzeuge weil wir werden im jahr
2020 etwa vier prozent elektro fahrzeuge
absetzen weltweit im jahr 20 21 dann
etwa acht prozent das hat keine
auswirkungen auf arbeitsplätze was wir
heute einen arbeitsplatz auswirkungen
diskutieren sind häufig auch natürlich
ein abkühlen der weltweiten
automobilkonjunktur wir haben weltweit
etwa ein rückgang gehabt im jahr 2009 10
von vier bis fünf prozent
in einigen märkten stärker in china
deutlich stärker etwa 8 prozent 9
prozent rückgang als der welt
automatisches nicht gewachsen und das
führt natürlich bei den firmen die dann
auch nicht so erfolgreich sind um
marktanteile zu gewinnen
auch zu einer anspannung hat der
arbeitsplätze wenn ich mir die letzten
jahre anschaue etwa die großen
automobilmessen dann wurden die autos
immer größer immer stärker immer teurer
und sie haben ja glänzen daran verdient
nicht unbedingt in europa aber zum
beispiel sehr stark in china hat das
nicht die umstellung erschwert im sinne
von acht müssen wir nicht ganz so
schnell voranschreiten wir verdienen
jetzt so tolles geld warum soll man uns
jetzt auf das auto konzentrieren muss
natürlich sie haben sehr angesprochen
aber das e auto per se setzt sich nicht
durch
aber auch die rahmen der für das e auto
braucht eine infrastruktur eine
ladeinfrastruktur
das e auto braucht vor allem co2 freien
strom wenn wir strom aus kohle
produzieren machen er autos überhaupt
keinen sinn aus klimapolitischer sich
das heißt wir brauchen die
rahmenbedingungen dafür das ist eine
volkswirtschaftliche aufgabe der
aufkäufe die gesellschaft wird wo diese
rahmenbedingungen geschaffen werden
dort setze ich dass er so dann sehr
schnell glaubens beispiel norwegen hier
in europa auch in china auch in ist
einmal der westküste in den usa haben
insbesondere eben auch steuerliche
anreize dazu geführt dass er sich
durchsetzen
das wird sich moderieren weil er autos
natürlich auch sehr wettbewerbsfähig
werden dann ich sage mal für wir haben
gerade einen neuen golf in den markt
gebracht mit plug in hybriden mit gas
antrieben mit diesel benzin an und
bringen in wenigen monaten den id3 ein
fahrzeug der gleichen größe in der
gleichen preiskategorie eben rein
elektrisch mit dann 300 bis 500
kilometer reichweite für viele kunden
wird der id3 der bessere kauf sein weil
einfach kostengünstig sie haben weniger
kosten pro kilometer
also weniger wartungskosten und immer
dort wo sie ausreichend
ladeinfrastruktur haben wo sie die
möglichkeit haben entweder in der arbeit
oder beim einkauf oder auch zuhause zu
laden ist für viele dann das elektroauto
die bessere wahl
aber dies das hört sich jetzt so an als
seien sie sehr entspannt aber immer wenn
man von ihnen äußerungen hört oder liest
dann sind das äußerungen die sagen wir
müssen jetzt auf die tube drücken wir
müssen ja jahre schleuniger weil es
könnte sein dass wir sonst den anschluss
verpassen
jetzt nicht unbedingt in richtung tesla
sondern auch der politischen
rahmenbedingungen die ja einen enormen
druck ausüben ja da zitieren sie mich
schon richtig weil einerseits bin ich
ein verfechter und habe das auch von
anfang an artikuliert wir brauchen
umwelt weil der erfolgreich zu seinen
starken heimatmarkt wir sind heute in
der welt sehr erfolgreich mit premium
automobilen weil wenn außer in der
folgezeit heimatmarkt haben wir haben
hier ein premium anteil von 30 prozent
audi mercedes porsche bmw im
wesentlichen dominieren diesem markt
dieser stark geheim
dem markt erlaubt uns dann die skalen zu
generieren um eben dann auch übersee in
den usa in japan in china sehr
erfolgreich zu sein wenn uns das mit
elektrofahrzeugen nicht gelingt also
wenn der hauptmarkt für elektrofahrzeuge
zb china wird oder usa wenn wir diese
möglichkeit des exports der
technologieexperte sehr sehr schwierig
deswegen müssen wir es schaffen
gemeinsam mit politik mit den
zulieferern hier in staaten heimatmarkt
zu schaffen hier müssen wir
demonstrieren dass elektromobilität
funktioniert und dann können wir dieses
neue produkt elektrofahrzeugen aber dann
verstehe ich nicht warum auf der anderen
seite die automobilindustrie sagt das
jetzt mal insgesamt
quasi sagt wir brauchen so ein auto wie
diesen großen panzer den sv weil wir
damit viel größere margen holen weil wir
damit quasi finanzieren diesen umstieg
in richtung elektro aber das sagt er
nicht die industrie die die industrie
muss aber muss den 1
wir sind sehr viel teurer mag sein dass
sie den eindruck gewinnen aber sie
müssen sagen die industrie muss erstmal
die autos bauen die der marktnachfrage
der kunde will und wir haben einfach in
den letzten jahren einen trend zu
größeren fahrzeugen vor allzu fahrzeugen
mit einer höheren sitzposition erlebt
weil das als erlebnis empfunden wird
auch sicherheit vermitteln die höhere
sitzposition natürlich auch über
übersicht vermittelt dadurch gibt es
einen trend der weltweit ist übrigens zu
den eher größeren fahrzeugen und zu suv
ist ja übrigens nicht einher geht mit
dem starken anwachsender verbräuchen es
brauche
20 10 15 prozent ja bei diversen
vielleicht aber das ist eine menge
ja diese menge auf der anderen seite
können sie den großen wandel zu einer
emissionsfreien mobilität nicht durch
kleinere fahrzeuge bewirken sie einfach
mal unser unser produktportfolio
angucken wir haben unser kleinstes auto
ist der volkswagen ab der sehr modernen
ist ein dreizylinder motor turbo
aufgeladene motor sehr effizient
leichtlaufreifen er dynamisch sehr guten
leichtes auto seit 95 gramm also das
kleinste 90 gramm co2
und dieses auto ist das einstiegs im
flotten ziele jetzt ab dem jahr 2021
liegen bei unter 100 gramm
das heißt sie können im prinzip das fall
wenn sie vier personen einigermaßen
sicher mit den geschwindigkeiten die
üblich sind 120 157 stundenkilometer
transportieren wollen
schaffen sie es nicht mit
verbrennungsmotoren dh diesel oder
benziner oder auch hybride weit unter
diese 95 macht ihnen das nicht große
kopfzerbrechen
doch natürlich das führt zur
anstrengungen wir haben aber eine gute
lösung dafür wir haben wir sind sehr
zuversichtlich dass unsere
elektrofahrzeugen die wirkliche
alternative sind mit co2 freiem strom
dann eben auch dann unsere flotten
emissionen deutlich absenken werden und
auch der richtige weg sind bis 2050 das
wollen wir auch völlig co2 frei auto
zusammen jetzt sagt aber der autofahrer
erst mal möchte ich ein großes ordnung
dann will ich ein schnelles auto der
preis ist mir jetzt gar nicht mal so
furchtbar wichtig das haben nicht alle
aussagen nicht alle das ist richtig aber
ich rede jetzt mal von denen die die
größeren autos kaufen einen touareg bei
ihnen zum beispiel und dann auf der
anderen seite sagen sie wir müssen aber
mit den verbräuchen runter mit dem co2
runter weist sich da nicht sozusagen die
katze in den schwanz weil der druck auf
sie als produzenten von autos ist enorm
groß und der kunde zieht ja noch nicht
so mit das wäre ja toll wenn der kunde
sagt naja gut also das prestige ist mir
jetzt mal nicht so wichtig und ich war
auch nicht immer mit fünf leuten im auto
deswegen nehme ich mal ein kleineres
auto und sie haben spaß daran weil er
liegt unter 100 bei co2 da beißt sich
die katze aber 1 7 sie bewerben ja auch
die großen auto sehe aber wir müssen
erstmal erstmal muss natürlich die autos
bauen die der kunde nach fragen die der
kunde will das sind erstmal etwas
größere autos die aber nicht exorbitant
mehr verbraucher haben der unterschied
jetzt zwischen seinem ab unserem
kleinsten auto und dann zum
mittelklasse-suv rock oder tiguan sind
20 25 prozent verbrauchen
das ist schon mehr verbrauch aber sie
können die flotten zu
und auch co2 freiheit nicht dadurch
erreichen dass sie mehr kleine fahrzeuge
verkaufen die zeiten sind vorbei
weil selbst wenn sie nur wir müssen 95
gramm flotten ziel erreichen wenn sie
mir ups verkaufen mehr kleine fahrzeugen
des hilft nichts sie werden im
durchschnitt nicht besser durch mehr
kleine fahrzeugen und das ist natürlich
eine industrielle logik dass in der
regel an den größeren fahrzeugen mehr
verdient wird
die margen sind dort höher und um den
wandel zu finanzieren glaube ich ist
schon legitim auf dem markt zu folgen
und diese größeren fahrzeuge zu bauen um
dann in summe in der flotte im mix mit
den elektrofahrzeugen auch die flotten
ziel zu erreichen und die co2
reduzierung und es wäre einfach ist
haben wir können nicht dem kunden sagen
was erfahren sollen das verstehe ich
aber sie verleiten doch den kunden diese
großen autos zu fahren und sagen dem ja
das ist auch gar nicht so schön auch da
ich weiter an anderen fahren rektor
einer großen liebe hündin diskussion
wenn sie wenn sie meint auf die
zulassungsstatistik schauen ja suvs
haben zugenommen aber das sind auch sehr
kompakte suv ist ein fahrzeug in der
größenordnung ein tick ross ist im
prinzip auf der basis von dem polo oder
einzige unterschied als etwa 35
millimeter höher ist ein gilt in die
kategorie der suvs vans in die
zulassungsstatistik gucken ist nach wie
vor mit großem abstand der volkswagen
golf das meistverkaufte fahrzeug in
deutschland auch über jahre hinweg und
auch in zukunft ich glaube dass wir
diese diskussion sehr stark über höhen
glaube sollten dem kunden wirklich die
freiheit lassen in welcher fahrzeughöhe
er gerne fährt der zahl dafür ja auch
ein bisschen mehr es ist absolut aus
meiner sicht vertretbar aus umweltsicht
diese fahrzeuge zu fahren die haben
häufig sehr effiziente motoren haben
plug in hybride mit ins elektrisch
fahren können und auch bei den
elektrofahrzeugen werden natürlich diese
höheren fahrzeugen die große rolle
spielt jetzt reden wir überall über co2
über klimaschutz et cetera
was haben sie persönlich für einen
eindruck warum die großen und ja auch
immer ps stärkere autos sich wirklich so
gut verkaufen gibt es da irgendeine an
link um das zu verstehen dass der
autokäufer das so toll wäre das ist ja
weltweit sind eher werden sie zu tun da
denn
unrecht dieser es gibt einen trend zu
etwas höhere sitzposition ja und aber es
ist nicht so dass jetzt alle eine klasse
größere fahrzeuge fahren wollen und dass
auf einmal alle den a6 kaufen statt
einem a5 den trend gibt es nicht in der
rede die fahrzeugsegmente sind sehr
stabil
es wird eine höhere fahrposition
investiert die autos werden etwas höher
hat natürlich auch damit zu tun dass
mehrere autos auf der straße sind und
man dann natürlich sich auch gegenseitig
da vielleicht hochschaukeln aber diese
fahrzeuge sind sehr umweltfreundlich
sind sehr sicher und entsprechend
einfach dem kundenbedürfnis ist auch
kein deutsches phänomen ist ein
weltweites phänomen wir sind es den usa
wir sehen sind china und ich glaube es
hätte keinen sinn für uns als
unternehmen sich dem trend zu
widersetzen sagen aber wir wollen kleine
autos verkaufen wenn der kunde die nicht
wählen es macht keinen sinn
wohin sie müssen sehen die die
automobilindustrie steht vor wirklich
großen umbrüchen diese investitionen in
elektrofahrzeugen neue antriebe kosten
viel geld das fahrzeug anhielt sich als
produkt software wird eine gewaltige
rolle spielen die autos werden sehr viel
sicherer werden in den nächsten jahren
und jahrzehnten das bedeutet
investitionen in diese investitionen
muss man verdienen und so gegeben die
verdienen wir auch mit es uns wenn wir
uns mal angucken weil wir jetzt sagen
das ist ja quasi eine art von
klimagipfel hier in davos wo co2 wo die
klimaziele schon zumindest in
erreichbare reichweiten gehen nämlich
zum beispiel den rückgang zwischen 1990
und jetzt im co2 bei der
energieerzeugung dann sind das 30
in anderen bereichen der industrie auf
30 beim verkehr ist eigentlich sozusagen
ein nullsummenspiel im gange das heißt
aber doch in zukunft müssen wir beim
verkehr auch uns noch ein paar andere
sachen überlegen jetzt sagen sie als
automobilproduzent um gottes willen doch
bitte nicht ohne autos ja das war denn
der strom herum nee das sagen nicht nur
wir sondern auch die die kunden wollen
natürlich die bevölkerung
individuelle mobilität und da wir gucken
jetzt in deutschland da gibt es
sicherlich in den großstädten den einen
oder anderen der das auto das sich vom
auto verabschiedet nur noch öffentlich
fährt oder carsharing fährt aber wählt
weil dieser trend zum auto ungebrochen
es gibt in vielen wachstumsländern in
china in lateinamerika in afrika in
vielen bereichen asiens ist der größte
wunsch vieler familie ein eigenes auto
mobil das automobil ja nicht nur für für
mobilität sorgt da sondern auch für
individuelle mobilität für freiheit
steht sich dorthin zu bewegen wo man
will und ich glaube unser ziel muss es
sein diese freiheit dieses
grundbedürfnis weiterhin zu befriedigen
aber eben co2 neutral ohne auswirkungen
auf das klima und das schaffen wir mit
einer elektrifizierung mit einer
schnellen elektrifizierung der autos und
dadurch dass wir die die primär
energieerzeugung also sind die energien
nicht mehr aus kohle produziert sondern
als erneuerbar macht aber nur dann sinn
wenn die energie tatsächlich aus den
erneuerbaren kommt ja und da haben wir
ja noch den ganzen weg zu gehen ja das
funktioniert jetzt im augenblick noch
nicht so richtig jetzt mal abgesehen
vielleicht von norwegen die an hohen
anteil an wasserkraft und damit an
energieerzeugung haben
hier wird ja auch darüber diskutiert wie
wir die ressourcen stärker schonen
können also nicht alles öl aus dem boden
zu holen um im zweifel auch energie zu
erzeugen elektrische energie wie das
manche länder immer noch tun müssen wir
nicht auch bei der ressourcenschonung im
automobilbereich überlegen was man tun
kann
batterie etwa ist ein großes problem um
der weiterzug ja absolut aber recycling
im automobil hat dann die lange
tradition
wir haben hohe quoten von recycling der
metalle im automobil da gibt es eine
etablierte struktur bei den batterien
werden wir in wenigen jahren auf einen
vollständig geschlossenen rohstoff
zyklus kommen die batterie werden dazu
90 prozent also wieder zum quasi wieder
kobalt nickel werden wir wieder
verwenden das sind sehr wertvolle
materialien auch nach dem ende eines
autolebens bleibt die batterie der
wertvollste bestandteil wir wollen zum
beispiel als hersteller die batterie
überhaupt nicht aus den händen geben
soll wir wollen die behalten über die
fahrzeug lebenszyklen da wird es am
anfang große investitionen geben in die
gewinnung der rohstoffe in die
aufarbeitung der rohstoffe werden dann
sehr schnell einen zyklus konnte diese
rohstoffe immer weiter und immer wieder
verwenden
das ist uns ist auch aus
wirtschaftlicher sicht ein großes
anliegen weil die batterie setzt jetzt
gibt es so einen fall wie zum beispiel
beim holländischen ministerpräsidenten
rutte wir gehen jetzt mit dem tempolimit
auf 100 runter dann hat er einen
ausdruck benutzt den mann ungewöhnlich
finden mag für einen premierminister hat
nämlich geschimpft und hat gesagt so ein
mist
es ist ja eigentlich schade weil 100 ist
wirklich sehr wenig aber wir müssen das
jetzt machen ja diese diskussion haben
wir eigentlich auch in deutschland die
wird ja immer stärker holland ist hat
relativ hohe stickoxid-emissionen man
sagt bedingt durch die hohe
landwirtschafts dichte die es dort gibt
das war eigentlich der anlass holland
ist ein vorreiter land in der in der
elektrifizierung die meistverkauften
autos jetzt in den letzten monaten in
holland bahn elektroautos oder hat mehr
ladestationen als deutschland hat
deutlich günstiger rahmenbedingungen für
die anschaffung von elektrofahrzeugen
holland ist durchaus ein vorreiter
brauchen wir eine
geschwindigkeitsreduzierung in
deutschland nein
ja das waren weil elektrofahrzeuge dazu
führen werden dass die leute langsamer
fahren sie für das was ich glaube kommt
dass jahreswechsel ihren sie verlieren
sehr viel reichweite mit
elektrofahrzeugen sie müssen der der
widerstand beim fahren steigt mit dem
quadrat geschwindigkeit das heißt wenn
sie ein fahrzeug geben indem
in niedrigen geschwindigkeiten bewegen
dann braucht es vielleicht 12 15
kilowattstunden auf 100 kilometer oder
12 15 kilowatt schon nebenbei werden
während der fahrt und wenn sie das
fahrzeug ging es dann mit mit 100 oder
200 kilometern pro stunde bewegen dann
braucht es ist zehnfach etwa 100 100
kommt das heißt die batterie ist dann
sehr schnell leer ist das für
automatisches tempo liegend was ein
automatisches tempolimit aber um dann
eben später nachzuladen und das sieht
man ja bei elektro fahrern auf der
autobahn fährt man eben dann angepasst
diese diskussion die hier stattfindet
ist eine quasi allumfassende diskussion
nicht nur über ressourcen nicht nur über
klima sondern auch über die frage wie
unternehmen im zweifel unter druck
geraten etwa durch die aktionäre
wenn wir uns die märkte anschauen die
berühmten märkte dann sieht man bei den
märkten da ist die nachhaltigkeit ein
riesen thema da gibt es fonds die nur in
nachhaltige produkte investieren kann so
ein großer konzern wie vw unter druck
geraten durch die aktionäre die
irgendwann sagen also das ist jetzt
nicht mehr unbedingt das wo ich meine
aktien von kaufen ja absolut es gibt
heute deutliche priorisierung richtung
nachhaltige aktien große fonds sind
angehalten nachhaltig zu investieren
ich glaube vw erfüllt alle
voraussetzungen für ein gutes investment
in eine nachhaltige nachhaltige
unternehmensführung weil wir eben sehr
stark auf co2 freisetzen das erste
unternehmen das ist so dass sich zur co2
freiheit committed hat dem jahr 2050 wir
haben pläne wir bauen unsere kraftwerke
um von kohle auf gas
wir sind mit sicherheit das unternehmen
weltweit das am meisten elektro
mobilität investiert in den breiten
modellprogramm wir bauen
batteriefabriken wir investieren in die
eingeschlossene rohstoff ketten rund um
die batterie also an
investment in die volkswagen-aktie
können sie mit gutem gewissen tätigen
wir werden sehen ob das dann so kommt
letztendlich aber können sie
nachvollziehen dass es bei den
unternehmen tatsächlich eine
verunsicherung auf der ebene der
vorstände gibt die auch dazu führt dass
ein joe kaeser sagte
kommen sie doch in den verwaltungsrat
bzw aufsichtsrat von siemens einer
freitags fünf user aktivisten wie frau
neubauer die das dann abgelehnt hat
würden sie so etwas auch machen würden
sie ja so etwas anbieten das thema
nachhaltigkeit und co2 freiheit spielt
für glauben jeder unternehmensstrategie
heute eine große rolle weil es einfach
das größte thema ist dass die menschheit
zu bewältigen hat und wir glaube ich
alle angehalten sind ein beitrag zu
leisten und unternehmen soll ja nicht
nur aktionäre und vor allem nicht
aktionäre kurzfristig bieten sondern
unternehmen hat eine gesellschaftliche
verantwortung und eine funktion und ich
glaube auch im sinne der aktionäre tun
wir sehr gut daran eben nachhaltig zu
wirtschaften und die größte
herausforderung ist co2 ist unsere co2
bilanz und deswegen glaube ich ist eine
strategie zur co2 freiheit auch für
viele unternehmen die richtige strategie
kann das denn sein dass wir auf dauer zb
in verantwortungsvollen positionen auch
im automobilbereich in unternehmen
überhaupt menschen finden die sagen wir
müssen komplett umsteuern wir müssen
eine völlig neue wirtschaft schaffen die
so nachhaltig ist dass wir die chance
haben tatsächlich auf diesem planeten
als menschen weiter zu existieren ja ich
glaube das unterschätzen sie viele der
unternehmensführer und man hat hier die
chance viele kollegen auch zu treffen
und sich auszutauschen
die sind genauso unterwegs viele
natürlich auch aus einer relativ
einfachen position software firmen mit
einem geringen football in denen sie
heute haben
es gibt heute schon viele unternehmen
die co2 neutralen wirtschaften
wir haben über große programme der
wiederaufforstung diskutiert hier gerade
in der forderungsverzicht alten bei der
der prince of wales auch anwesend war
also dieses thema nachhaltigkeit co2
freiheit ist für viele
unternehmenslenker erste pläne was haben
sie denn für eine erfahrung gemacht wenn
sie mit anderen unternehmenslenkern hier
gesprochen haben wie ernsthaft diese
auseinandersetzung ist man hat ja
manchmal auch so ein bisschen den
eindruck nachhaltigkeit ist ein schöner
begriff
das ist auch ein begriff des marketing
da kann ich wunderbar mit verben wie
ernsthaft sind die ich glaube das ist
das eine große ernsthaftigkeit gibt in
der diskussion aber natürlich die
ausgangspositionen sehr unterschiedlich
sind
es ist sehr schwierig zum beispiel
luftverkehr co2 neutral zu stellen der
flugzeuge elektrisch zum fliegen zu
bekommen das wird sehr schwierig sein
ist in unserer industrie in der mobilen
diese relativ teuer wir brauchen
infrastruktur aber auch
ladeinfrastruktur elektrofahrzeuge sind
teuer hohe investitionen und es gibt
neue industrien da geht es leichter da
kann man software dienstleistungen sind
natürlich leichter so dass der
anspannung grad unterschiedlich ist
natürlich auch die commitments die
zeitpläne aber ich glaube dass es bald
nur noch wenige unternehmen geben wird
die sich einem klimaziel verweigert
kommt das von den vorständen selber von
den geschäftsführern selber oder sind es
die kinder der geschäftsführung der
vorstände die da druck machen ja das ist
ich kann mir das ja am mittagstisch aber
ganz gut vorstellen falls sie mal zeit
dazu überhaupt haben die ja das essen
das ist ein guter plan die wir glaube
ich glaube das ist einfach jeden von uns
ein schlechtes gefühl gibt wenn wir vor
allem in verantwortlichen positionen in
denen wir sind unsere welt in einem
zustand an die nächste generation
übergeben der der nächsten generation
nicht gefällt das gibt uns allen zu
denken und das sind sie ja die kinder
das ist sind die medien die öffentliche
diskussion aber sicherlich auch ein
großes teil selbst verantwortung
wie haben sie das empfunden was gestern
passiert nämlich die aussagen von donald
trump und auf der anderen seite die
aussagen einer kreatur berg die ja
durchaus fast schon auf der anderen
seite so umstritten ist wie donald trump
umstritten es die wahren diametral
auseinander
ja wobei ich auch wir hatten die
gelegenheit ja dann noch mit der tram zu
abend zu essen und ich fand auch seine
äußerungen eigentlich positiv war wie
wir hat gesprochen über er befürwortet
aufforstungsprogramme man muss die man
darf auch den dem den usa nicht unrecht
tun die usa haben sich in der klima
effizienz also im co2 footprint pro
einwohner schneller verbessert in den
letzten jahren als zb deutschland auch
unter der treppe administration in den
usa ist nach wie vor
es ist das zweitgrößte land bei der
investition in nachhaltige energie in
wind- und solarenergie
gerade an der west und an der ostküste
gibt es natürlich extrem komitee politik
zum thema klimawandel also man darf die
usa da nicht unterschätzen da passiert
sehr viel aus der deutschen position zu
argumentieren ist ein bisher hier in der
schweiz haben wir etwa obwohl wir hier
jetzt sehr stark heizen müssen haben wir
etwa den halben co2 footprint als in
deutschland wir haben in schweden 4
tonnen pro einwohner gegenüber 10 in
deutschland also es ist so um uns herum
passiert viel auch in amerika passiert
viel trump hat gestern abend gefragt wie
sich denn die windenergie entwickelt
fand ich ein sehr positives zeichen und
ich glaube in dem maß wie sich ja auch
der klimawandel dann umsetzt im
geschäftspläne der unternehmen auch in
neuen geschäftsfeldern erneuerbare
energien co2 ärmer die
produktionsprozesse es werde immer mehr
kann das ist auch eben geschäftsmodelle
neue geschäftsmodelle gibt da wird es
dann auch wirklich für die für die leute
die vielleicht nicht zu stark an den
klimawandel glauben auch ein thema mit
dem sondern setzen werden ist für sie
persönlich das gefühl der verantwortung
was sie gerade angesprochen haben für
eine nächste generation der auslöser
oder ist es die sorge dass wir
möglicherweise in politische
gesellschaftliche situationen kommen
durch den klimawandel in dem der druck
der politik so enorm groß wird
dass sie sagen müssen das kriegen wir
nicht mehr hin ja ich würde es nicht am
druckfest machen weil die die politik
können wir tendenziell eher mehr tun für
den um schneller umzusteuern
sie haben eigentlich haben dass die
us-regierung mehr wir haben sehr moderat
ideen zur co2 also da ist ja aber es
muss eben nicht nicht alles teurer
werden die motivation kommt mit
sicherheit schon aus der diskussion mit
der nächsten generation und das
lostreten werk sagt ganz offen zugeben
wir schon nahe weil es einfach die
generation ist die dies in dieser welt
leben wird die wir gerade für deren
leben vorbereiten und da haben wir eine
verantwortung
auf der einen seite müssen wir auch
sehen dass wirklich ja das thema und sie
sagen ist hierauf in davos das große
thema der welt ist co2 klimaerwärmung
und unseren sprint zurückzufahren bzw
sogar co2 wieder aus der atmosphäre zu
übernehmen das heißt unsere kunden
werden auch nach und nach dieses
kriterium stärker in den vordergrund
stellen er hat sind also auch angehalten
wenn wir marktfähig bleiben wollen co2
frei produkte das gilt nicht nur für das
automobil sondern gilt für viele
produkte so dass auch der markt nach co2
freiheit auf co2 freiheit drängen wird
und es sind die aktionäre über ihre
großen pensionsfonds als sagen wir dass
das große gefühl der gesellschaft ist
dass wir handeln müssen weder zum berg
verleiht dem ganzen dann noch eine
gewisse dramatik und auch eindruck ich
glaube das tut uns im prinzip gut uns
damit auseinanderzusetzen
aber ich glaube schon dass die
gesellschaft auch weltweit in bewegung
ist da gibt es noch ein paar ausnahmen
paar rückständige australien com bietet
sich nicht lateinamerika zu den
klimazielen usa unter trump
administration
aber das wird abnehmen in dem maße die
welt ist in bewegung und deswegen bin
ich auch optimistisch dass wir mit dem
was dem was die welt an innovationen
bieten wird in den nächsten jahren dass
wir letztlich diese herausforderung
und meistern werden wir wollen uns offen
hätte ist ganz herzlichen dank dass ich
bleiben
[Musik]